her comments on immigration were a
complete fabrication true a hack with no
brains insist migrants were beaten with
Reigns I speak of White House
correspondent for the Grio and MSNBC can
contributor April Ryan Who Won't Give Up
on the debunk claim that border agents
whipped migrants back in 2021. you
remember the photo it's the one the
media and the White House jumped on
demanding border agents be punished
before an investigation concluded it was
noting that those are just Reigns to
control the horses
in fact they're a lot like the leash
Jill Biden uses to control Joe
but like Joy Behar with her claws and a
day old Donut
Ryan Can't Let It Go
the southern border is not just Mexicans
it is Haitians it's Africans as we've
seen particularly with that issue with
the Haitians being whipped with the
Reigns or the horses
but what is there well let me just
correct you right there because actually
the investigation concluded that the
whipping did not occur
I was totally different I'm sorry um
yeah I'm gonna leave you as uh uh
corrected where the hell where the hell
is she been
holy crap and she's so virtuous wearing
the mask five years into the end of a
pandemic you know it's bad when you're
getting corrected by a Serial liar like
majorcus
here he is
expressing his displeasure
but at least he finally admitted
publicly that he got it wrong but Ryan
still kept on it later tweeting the
photo with the caption maybe it's just
me but
I bet she's still looking for Jesse
smollett's attackers
but let me pause here for some breaking
news Ryan it is just you no buts you are
a closed-minded incompetent dumbass
it's just that no one had the nerve to
tell you the truth because you would cry
racism that's what sucks about wokeism
everyone around you thinks they're
helping you by lying to you but imagine
what a better journalist you could be if
people actually helped you become one
instead of the opposite it's why I give
pointers to Brett Bear every single day
if it wasn't for me he'd still be
rapping on street corners
inside
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll get to that in a minute
that Christmas party video will never
disappear it will never die as long as
I'm here I will be playing I'll be
playing that at your funeral if you die
before me which will happen because I
will murder you in your sleep okay all
right thanks we'll be back after this
yes
Kennedy what is what could be your
explanation other than an ambivalence
towards the truth like not bothering to
do her research that's a reporter Okay
so the White House is trying to pull the
press credentials from the New York Post
and and they're working hard to be able
to do that there's basically a law right
now that says the White House can't do
that we have to have a free and open
press so but if they are going to I
think they should start with her yeah
because the most important thing is to
tell the truth that's number one not
what you wish the truth was not what you
thought you saw also she's a journalist
which means she should be doing research
she should read the 500 page report that
came out nine months after that
photograph was published and all of
these agents the entire Brigade was
disbanded because of a misrepresentation
the photographer came out and said that
didn't happen it was a bad angle
meanwhile people like Maxine Waters are
saying it's worse than slavery yeah
there are plenty of bad things happening
in this country there are plenty of
racial disparities that still exist she
should go cover those you know do you
think she was being serious like she
actually or was she faking like she
thought it was still real I feel like we
have a like reoccurring theme on this
episode it's the first episode so in
this case
um
I ice
I think two two points on this one uh
one obviously the mask with the glasses
is fogged up the glasses so she can't
see you know it's a little blurry so
maybe the steering devices for the
horses uh is not is not a whip but
here's the thing she won we're talking
about it she's back in in The Graces I
at one time she was a political
journalist now she's doing the one thing
unfortunately that works in this country
we see it every time as soon as you put
race because she set it up it was
Haitians and Africans I was like here we
go and they're being whipped so it's
right and then everyone stopped
the positive thing was Mallorca finally
admitted it but it shouldn't have took
that coming from her he should have had
a press conference apologizing to those
men and women who serve on the border
because he literally ruined their lives
their families lives like we've talked
about over and over again that's not
good enough yeah you stand corrected no
where is your correction where is the
president of the United States
correction who literally ruined these
people's lives and for her to bring that
up like I said she got her moment we're
talking about it she's back in the
headlines so maybe she'll get picked up
on a she'll be on a panel
not All-Star panel but she'll be on the
panel somewhere to talk about it that's
what's sad but yeah thank you for
finally saying something bro yeah what
do you think cat
well I've just been thinking this entire
time about what was she doing all day
before that like like what exactly was
she doing because I thought reporters
like you said they're supposed to do the
research she didn't even Google it like
she could have done that on the toilet
yeah she it would have been very simple
to know the answer to that question so
if you don't do any work and you just
ask whatever random question I don't
think that you're even doing your job
and then her inclination after that
should have been I mean she should have
been humiliated right she should have
been so embarrassed I've made mistakes
before whenever I make a mistake I'm so
humiliated and I blow people's phones up
like are you mad at me don't hate me I'm
so sorry instead she picks up her phone
and she's like actually I want to try to
spread this lie because I'm the only one
who matters here and I want to try to
get other people to believe this lie
just so that I don't look bad but you
made a mistake admit it own up to it and
maybe Google Google it the next time it
is amazing I mean people talk about
living in different silos but this is
like even like even liberals and
Democrats know this story you have to be
real you have to be really sequestered
you have to be on an island perhaps
Epstein's Island to actually not know
this story to tyrus's point though
President Biden came out and said that
those agents will pay for their
misconduct right and said those images
were horrific this is the first time
we've heard the administration deal with
this at all true at all and it was kind
of an aside in a question so to your
point I mean there's more that should
have been said right a long time ago
maybe she's an American hero for forcing
him to say something maybe it was a
trick maybe she's that secret genius and
tricked him into saying it do you think
that's possible
I'm so glad I got my orcas to confess
that this was wrong but weren't you
proud of him for sprouting little
nutlets for once yes yeah yeah yeah they
popped out just one yeah
that's so true anyway up next a city
takes away the right to judge workers
based on Heights hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else